[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
un tema deportivo la carrera ciclista
por excelencia que este mes de julio se
disputa aquí en francia el tour de
francia para ello nos acompañan en este
estudio también le metro al periodista
deportivo en el diario l équipe
bienvenido de allianz muy buenas mi
compañera anna maría ospina periodista
deportiva aquí en rode france
internacional bienvenida y benoit vittek
periodista deportivo especializado en
ciclismo bienvenido
el tour de francia ya en marcha hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
tres mil trescientos cincuenta
kilómetros en bicicleta veintiuna etapas
dos contrarreloj individuales cinco
llegadas en alto son las cifras de la
edición de este año del tour de francia
que arrancó el pasado 1 de julio no en
francia arrancó sino en copenhague en
dinamarca la llegada será el 24 de julio
como siempre a los campos elíseos aquí
en parís un espectáculo deportivo a la
prueba ciclista más prestigiosa del
mundo pero también un escaparate y una
vitrina para francia hacia el mundo sus
regiones su turismo la economía de ello
también mucho en el tour que ya cumple
con esta su edición número 109 vamos a
analizar también el papel de los
corredores latinos colombianos este año
en la prueba y también el primer tour
femenino que arrancará el 24 de julio
antes de ello portadas diario l'equipe
el diario de mi compañero damián no
perder el norte se refiere el diario al
arranque de esta edición en tierras de
europa del norte en dinamarca y luego en
el norte de francia pues france hace
referencia en esta portada a la
incidencia que la comida está teniendo
en la carrera ya se han registrado
varios casos si un puñado de corredores
han tenido que abandonar la prueba y la
revista especializada ciclisme a gas
dedica su portada al vigente campeón el
esloveno tadej borracha en caso de que
gane este tour sería el tercero antes de
cumplir 24 años toda una hazaña bueno
también la cob y el arranque en
dinamarca el todos contra ponga cha
contra el favorito con el esloveno con
qué titulares nos quedamos en esta
edición que llega ya su ecuador
pues yo diría la batalla contra ponga
char está claro que es la primera
edición desde que ponga char ha tomado
el mundo no digamos del ciclismo mundial
am ponían la red las dos últimas dos
últimas de tour de francia es la primera
vez que ponga echar realmente tiene
rivales que le pueden
robar digamos su subtítulo de mejor ser
visto del mundo actualmente a la
titulares han llegado las etapas de los
alpes y de repente ha llegado esa
inyección de emoción no a la prueba
desde todos con trapo gacha que fuera un
poco monótona por
eso no hay que nunca darlo por vencido y
es un va a combatir eso pero lo que
vimos en los alpes una muestra es que
tanto viven garcon yumbo y otros
corredores pues no se la van a dejar
fácil si él quiere ser el mejor pues le
tiene que ganar a ellos y se anuncia una
batalla bastante intensa en la tercera
semana sabemos bien llegar el danés que
es el actual maillot amarillo
ustedes me corrigen porque yo no estoy
puesta en ciclismo para eso les tengo a
ustedes benoit todos con trapo gacha
y por fin sucediendo por fin sucedió
pero todos contra la polio puede ser
sobre todo el equipo de yumbo misma que
es el equipo de jonas divinidad y han
hecho una hazaña colectiva el otro día
para quitarle el maillot amarillo así
que ahora a ver todos contra el jumbo
visma también para los 10 días que nos
quedan de cara para los que no estemos
puestos en ciclismo lo primero hablamos
tanto de poda chad el esloveno pero
cuáles serían las claves para analizar
esta figura que haya ganado ya dos tours
de francia que pueda lograr la hazaña de
un tercero antes de los 24 años como
explicaríamos las cualidades de este
ciclista damián alguien que no esté
familiarizado con la prueba paga echarás
un superdotado del ciclismo primero ganó
su primer tour en el año 2020 a los casi
22 años el ya antes de cumplir 22 años
así que era el ciclista más joven de la
historia
moderna
también diría llegar por ganar esa
prueba
así que es un fenómeno primero es un
crack que es el nuevo el y merck es el
ciclista belga que ha ganado cinco veces
el tour de francia el mejor ciclista
de dos tiempos
sabe ganar en las montañas pero también
en sprint
lo sabe todo es un superdotado que tiene
bogotá que no tenga crédito que
cualidades que es un ciclista muy
completo que siempre se le nota que lo
hace con pasión con gusto que además es
capaz de perder el mayo amarillo y
pensar que mañana lo puedo recuperar o
sea que nunca se da por vencido y juega
mucho con eso a pesar de que tiene
siempre está pensando en lo que viene
después es un corredor completo en todos
los terrenos que se le pongan me
impresiona su inteligencia táctica y
cómo maneja la carrera a su edad también
me jóvenes lo que estábamos diciendo su
juventud es algo extraordinario en la
historia del ciclismo sus capacidades
físicas también parecen ser algo que
pocas veces hemos visto pero también lo
tiene en la cabeza y yo me imagino que
para un pequeño país como es eslovenia
tener un campeón de la talla de pagasa
debe ser toda una revolución también es
una figura está claro que eslovenia me
parece que cuenta con dos millones de
habitantes y el 65% de la población está
practicando algún deporte
algún estudio pueda echar ese embajador
como como lo está diciendo no es el
único que podemos hacer referencia
también a educación sino que es el
jugador de baloncesto en
es un fenómeno también pero claro ahora
voy a echar es el el rey no hay un poco
de su disciplina en una disciplina que
se mundializa que es internos en
internacionaliza en europa y fuera así
que va a marcar época nos hablamos de
una generación de deportistas eslovenos
que están abriendo digamos como grandes
embajadores de eslovenia en el mundo
bueno el danés jonas ha decido porque
esto me han enseñado a pronunciar vigor
aunque lo leamos escrito binge cárter
para que nadie se confunda ya digo las
dos formas y así nos entendemos el danés
ha conseguido el maillot amarillo en los
alpes tiene posibilidades reales de
arrebatar aprovecha este tour de francia
sí por dos cosas la primera el año
pasado ya estuve en el podio fue segundo
demostró que le podía dar la pelea ponga
echar que llegó mucho más fuerte
entonces big en garde llega más
preparado su equipo jumbo todo el
trabajo lo tiene para él se inicialmente
iban a trabajar para primor yo glitch
que era su líder natural pues vieron que
con vengar podían ir mejor entonces
pienso que si tiene posibilidades
y que no pierda el amarillo en la última
etapa como sucedió el año pasado por
cierto este año hablando de el danés
debe indicar el tour de francia como
decíamos no ha salido de francia sino de
dinamarca de copenhague quizá muchos de
los que nos están viendo oyendo cómo
puede ser que el tour de francia' parta
de copenhague como lo explicamos quien
quiera haber
empezaste a la emisión hablando de la
vitrina que hoy francia representa
hablar a francia nuestros dos países
alrededor también están interesado en
esta vitrina y ya son casi 70 años desde
los años 50 países bajos fue el primer
país en fuera de francia en acoger la
salida oficial del tour de francia se
han dado cuenta de lo interesante que
puede ser tener un evento mundial como
el tú de francia y este año pues ha sido
dinamarca que también es un país que
tiene muchísima cultura ciclista
20-25 años que tenían esta idea de salir
de hacer el tour salir desde dinamarca
han tenido problemas con dopaje con
varias cosas de la historia del tour y
del ciclismo tenían que hacerlo el año
pasado no han podido por kobe pues han
tenido este año y ha sido un éxito
absoluto por cierto que no estuvo
cubriéndolo mi compañera no estoy en
copenhague cuéntanos qué ambiente se
vivía en ese mar que en esa salida
quiero añadir que hace años que lo
querían hacer que copenhague es la
ciudad mundial del ciclismo todo el
mundo se transporta en bicicleta de
hecho tuve la fortuna de llegar al
aeropuerto en bicicleta algo que no
había podido hacer con saca con mi
maleta para poder tomar el vuelo de
regreso a parís el ambiente fue
increíble se veía un amor y una pasión
por el tour de francia pero por el
ciclismo general incluso celebrar a
todos los ciclistas sin importar la
nacionalidad la cantidad de gente que
estuvo la presentación de equipos nunca
lo había visto en otras ciudades incluso
aquí en francia o en españa donde son
tan apasionados y la gente conocía
conocida de lo que estaba hablando
parecía un concierto de rock si lo puedo
resumir de esa manera y en las etapas
tanta gente en las calles pero con un
respeto por los ciclistas
nadie se les iba encima los dejaban
respirar los dejaban hacer su trabajo
que es competir algo que muchos
criticamos y allá había un respeto por
el trabajo de esos corredores que
durante cuatro horas pedalea sudán y
pelean para ganar y lo respetan tanto
pues que estaban ahí siguiendo los y
aplaudiendo los un país desde luego con
mucha cultura ciclista en a dinamarca sí
y de marca
bueno además tiene corredores bastantes
buenos dentro del pelotón también hay es
aliciente por el público para el público
de poder apoyar a sus ciclistas y por
ejemplo el camping magnífico kings se
llevó el maillot de mejor escalador
durante una semanita ganó una etapa así
que claro que a nivel deportivo también
la cosa está viviendo ahí muy fuerte
pero no hay montaña
de
bicicleta que no es como el suyo como
colombia que precisamente se distingue
por tener una orografía mucho más
complicada señaló porque muchos de los
corredores que ahora vemos son
escaladores es porque han viajado
durante sus vacaciones a prepararse en
montaña en los alpes franceses
para poder competir en el tour y que un
buen escalador holandés o danés desde
luego no ha practicado mucho en su país
guitard ha crecido en el norte de
dinamarca donde lo único que encontraba
era llano
en arena y gente pero luego como se ha
convertido profesional haciendo récord
tiempos récord en subidas de andora y
ahí pudo demostrar su talento de
escalador pero no lo pudo hacer en
dinamarca obviamente más de asuntos la
cob y cómo está influyendo la comida en
la prueba porque llevan varios
corredores un puñado de corredores que
se ha tenido que retirar también 17
abandonos que llevamos 9 después de
ellas ya de carreras más o menos me
parece que son 6 los corredores que
tuvieron que abandonar por sufrir por
padecer el hobbit y seis corredores pero
también directivos
asistentes y demás mucha gente está
afectada ahí me parece no en la burbuja
del tour digamos así que hay cada vez
más restricciones dentro de la carrera
hacia hacia los periodistas pero también
el público en general queríamos
colocarse el primer tour con cierta
normalidad pero parece ser que no las
primeras etapas se vio cierta normalidad
para el trabajo y señalar que este año
las reglas cambiaron el año anterior si
dos corredores o los integrantes del
equipo tenían kobe pues todo el equipo
debía abandonar había mucha más
seguridad eso este año del equipo de
tarea época char que han tenido dos
corredores que tienen tuvieron que
retirarse el manager también se ha de se
ha ido de la carrera y en otro corredor
que ha dado positivo pero con nivel
incisión bastante bajo para que no
represente un peligro para los otros
alrededor así que siguen aún teniendo
dos positivos y aún más que en años
precedentes hubiera significado no nos
vamos a casa ya significa de pronto
correr menos como equipo y buscar otra
estrategia además el tour ha aconsejado
a los ciclistas evitarse el fish y
autógrafos por la comida ante el aumento
de casos algo que parecía increíble hace
un mes pero la unión ciclista
internacional por lo que se ve ha
reactualizado el protocolo no si no me
equivoco los casos subieron tanto que
durante las primeras etapas había mucha
más libertad lo señalaba en copenhague
estaban los ciclistas más cercas de su
público pero tuvieron que tomar esta
medida para evitar que pues se vuelva un
problema ya sea al final del turia
llegando a la mitad ante el aumento de
contagios también que estamos viviendo
aquí en europa me quedan muchas cosas
por preguntarles entre ellos el tour de
francia femenino que por lo que se va a
empezar el 24 de julio cuando acabe el
masculino y también les quiero preguntar
cómo influye económicamente para la
economía francesa toda la prueba va a
ser en unos minutos hacemos una breve
pausa y enseguida continuamos aquí en
primera plana hasta ahora
[Música]
seguimos analizando el tour de francia
que se disputa durante el mes de julio
por toda la geografía francesa con
damián l metro periodista deportivo en
lake y para maría ospina compañera de
recién especializada en deporte como
también lo es vino a vittek periodista
deportivo independiente especializado en
ciclismo damián tu periódico l'equipe el
periódico fundador quiere darle vida y
oxígeno a una carrera que ve demasiado
mono terna en una editorial pública hace
unos días y pedía hacer una gran alianza
para poner las cosas complicadas a pacha
y así reavivar la carrera hay un
sentimiento o al menos había hasta las
etapas de los alpes de cierta monotonía
en la prueba porque tuvimos un
sentimiento de deja vú diría que época
lleva ganando los últimos dos en tours
cogió la amarilla en los primeros días y
además con una cierta
exhibición no en los tramos de adoquines
en los tramos llanos digamos contra el
viento también y ahora que llega la
montaña pues ya estaba ya se puso el
líder así que tuve
en l'equipe hemos tenido esa sensación
de decir
algo desde yahoo y ahora que sin llegar
el danés
ha metido fuego en la carrera creo que
tenemos
ahora tenemos esa batalla ese duelo
excitante porque será seguramente un
duelo entre el danés y el esloveno para
los próximos días y que nos va a llevar
hasta hasta los pirineos la semana que
viene llega bien y cómo se lleva desde
un diario como el equipo que francia nos
lleve sin ganar un tour creo que es
desde el año a ver si no me equivoco en
1989 no o de 75 210 del 85 se han pasado
ya treinta y pico hay 37 años en ganar
un tour un ciclista francés cómo se
lleva desde un diario como el equipo
pues
tenemos mucha esperanza hace tres años
en
2019 tuvimos
esa esperanza de contiguo pino y román
verde de ganar esa carrera esa
oportunidad no llegó
ahora pues hay ese fenómeno que se llama
poca echar que ha irrumpido en el
escenario mundial
bueno también es es una cuestión de
presión mediática de presión popular que
puede explicar
esa posición de llevar tantos años sin
ganar una prueba que se organiza en
francia y que forma parte del patrimonio
no de la historia de francia le arranca
también a benoit cómo se lleva tantos
años treinta y pico años sin que francia
consiga ganar el doble grande a en el
2010 y el 9 francia estaba loca para
tino y también para la seal y porque
cuando el que además de no haber tenido
un ganador del tour durante 37 años
hubieron 15 20 años en quien me había
ilusión ningún francés estaba en
capacidad de luchar para esto y cuando
un francés como pino se ha encontrado en
esta capacidad pues todo el país lo
esperaba ahora ya no
también es que es hibernar lo demuestra
hace 37 años que no han ganado francia
pero hay muchísimos países que han
ganado en estos años porque hablamos de
internacionalización del ciclismo pues
se ve en los palmarés y en quién gana y
cuando hay ahora 40 o 50 que es tan
capaz de luchar para la victoria no es
el mismo que cuando habían tres o cuatro
hacen siete de cien años y por eso
entonces ahora hay que esperar francia
tiene que esperar su turno lo que las
que no van a esperar son ellas a partir
del 24 de julio arranca el tour de
francia femenino una primera edición qué
características va a tener la prueba
femenina y por qué llega ahora la
primera edición porque en 2022 son 22
equipos con seis corredoras cada una
tendrá ocho etapas para resumir los
cuatro planos cuatro de media montaña
dos de mediana perdón y dos de alta
montaña van a visitar todo el este de
francia y tendrá corredores de talla
internacional tan importantes como
mariana voz band blood en el isa longo
borghini
una colombiana
y es muy cariñosa la corredora
colombiana del equipo español
y porque esta vez pues el tour decide
tenerlo incluso su primera etapa va a
salir desde la torre eiffel antes que la
última etapa de los hombres que llega a
los para darle toda esa vitrina pues
benoit que estará cubriendo la carrera
lo dirá mejor que yo porque estaba
porque ya han esperado muchísimo han
esperado mucho con arrastre cuando se
espera tanto y no se le da el foco a
ellas también se hace porque otros las
disciplinas otras otras carreras otras
competiciones lo hacen y al final lo
tienes que hacer un poco por arrastre o
no también porque el ciclismo de ruta ha
sido machista y no a gran y no ha dado a
las mujeres el hueco que merecen en
cualquier sitio de la sociedad y en
ciclismo de ruta eso no ha existido
hasta hasta los últimos años y ahora ha
crecido ha crecido o es hasta tener un
tour de francia los los grandes equipos
de machos también ahora tienen equipos
de mujeres y hay otra prueba como el
padre uvi y es una de las clásicas más
emblemáticas del ciclismo la reina de
clásicas es famosa por ser muy dura por
el tema de los padres que es algo brutal
pues las mujeres han tenido el primer
parís roubais femenino el año pasado y
han demostrado que están capaces capaces
de eso también lo que decía paula patiño
yo hablé con ella el mes pasado y me
decía que cuando empezó ciclismo lo hizo
con una figura local hernando gaviria
que es el padre de fernando que adhiere
a uno de los mejores velocistas del
momento
hernando y que ese entrenador le decía
vente a hacer ciclismo conmigo y paola
le decía pero si tengo es un deporte de
hombres yo sólo veo carreras de hombres
y no me dio un futuro aquí es demasiado
duro para mujeres pues ya vemos que no
lo es no es demasiado duro van a tener
su oportunidad y cualquier chica en el
mundo puede también soñar con hacerlo
por supuesto siempre que romper esos
techos a veces lo social se cuela en lo
deportivo y esta semana vimos un parón
en mitad de una etapa producido por un
grupo ecologista dernier renovación' que
hace un mes obligó también a parar un
partido de tenis en el roland garros
lanzar gritos por causas justas como el
desastre planetario aprovechando la gran
vitrina que es el tour como lo ven a
damián a
cualquier protesta si quieres que
sea
y si buscas impacto tienes que hacerlo
en un escenario que la gente mire y pues
el tour es uno de los escenarios más
grandes que francia tiene
en el radio muestra que el tú sigue
siendo una gran caja de resonancia
damián sí sí yo creo que el tour está
difundido en casi 200 países en el mundo
son millones de personas que lo están
viendo cada día casi cada día
no es la primera vez en que hay un
especial de protestas y parecida
llevamos muchos años protestas antes
eran protestas sociales no por por
ejemplo por una etapa del tour que tuvo
que ser anulado fue una protesta social
en el norte y eso de procesos sociales
también es una vitrina de la marca
francia hacia el mundo para el turismo
para la economía francesa
me gustaría que explicáramos también
cómo se diseña un tour de francia el
recorrido un tour las ciudades por las
que pasa qué criterios hay hay
candidaturas como cómo se organiza esto
también igual podemos exponer algunos
argumentos cada uno y por ejemplo hay
una regla que forma parte un poco de esa
historia del tour que es la alternativa
entre los alpes y los pirineos que son
los dos las dos principales dificultades
de las montañas de francia que siempre
tienen que estar en este trazado que
casi si primero los alpes y luego los
pirineos y al año siguiente al revés al
revés
ya partir de ahí ya se construye un
pequeño mapa vale de acuerdo si también
pues si hay candidaturas casi cualquier
ciudad de francia pide que el tour y
llegue en su en su ciudad si que quiere
good luck que es el director de la
carrera y también diseña el recorrido
pues con fusión con director del tour de
francia dice no que este año el año que
venga tenemos que ir por lo menos a
acabar acabamos en parís pero tenemos
marsella tenemos que hacer el tourmalet
y voto y luego gusta ok
como voy a hacer algo interesante en el
plan deportivo sabiendo que tengo que
cruzar estas cuatro o cinco ciudades y
él lo va manejando así pensando en él en
las obligaciones que le dan porque tiene
que ir a adaptar ciudad y tal ciudad y
luego él quiere hacer algo interesante
en el plan deportivo y
en este plan deportivo ha cambiado mucho
la manera de pensar el tour en los
últimos años para que la carrera este
excitante cada día para el espacio a
cada corredor si eso hay buenos
velocistas entonces que tengan etapas
planas buenos escaladores tengan más
etapas de montaña con mayor dificultad y
ya lo que es en cada ciudad que
finalmente es elegida se le avisa con
años de anterioridad para que tenga la
posibilidad de prepararse tanto
económicamente como logísticamente
porque debe recibir la caravana del tour
que no es pequeña entonces para la
propia ciudad es un digamos un desafío
particular poder participar en sobre
francia y su respuesta
haga y se encarga de todo lo que es
seguridad
y de dar a la organización y a la
carrera lo que necesita en temas de
infraestructuras cada ciudad es hablar
es decir desde llegar pero también el
tour pasa por pueblitos pequeños donde
no hay ni un cajero automático y tienen
que recibir toda esa infraestructura que
imagino que el impacto deberá ser
tremendo tanto que económicamente para
esos pequeños pueblos muchas personas
que ven el tour de francia la comunidad
de sus casas dice mira esto se ve bonito
el próximo año voy allá porque no
entonces también les ayuda a mover su
economía así tengan una inversión al
principio de costos de organización
ellos lo ven
tiempo después que es una ciudad que se
hace conocer el mundo económicamente
recibe mucho impacto
y pueblitos así a veces se hacen con más
al nivel del departamento y el
departamento va a tener un acuerdo con
la organización del tour diciendo pues
yo yo yo me encargo a encargo yo pago y
pues este año quiero una etapa en esta
ciudad el año que venga vamos a esta
otra y tal y tal y tal así funciona por
ejemplo para la salida de la última
etapa del tour
unos años sale siempre del departamento
de yvelines y va a ser el caso para unos
años más y luego tendrán otro acuerdo
con otro con el departamento de la magia
del turno que es uno de los pocos
eventos a nivel mundial que puede llegar
a la puerta de tu casa incluso cuando
uno vive en un pueblecito claro de
francia o incluso fuera que el año que
viene por ejemplo saltar de bilbao y
pasará por pueblos hitos de buscar y va
a hacer de las mejores fiestas que hemos
conocido en el duro yo yo me imagino que
con 20 etapas y un prólogo nunca queda
suficiente espacio tiempo para contar el
anecdotario la cantidad de historias
personales que pueden vivir los
periodistas que cubren el tour de
francia de anécdotas que podéis contar
así algo rápido si tomas un día como el
de ayer en el cds pues tienes anécdotas
para un mes entero claro no sé si hay
salieron el día de antes que white hart
que es una de las superestrellas de este
tour este año está bajando está bajando
en la última el último puerto pues lo
está bajando después de la etapa ya ha
acabado su día lo está bajando en su
bici con su mayor verde que significa
que es uno de los mejores de la carrera
y se encuentra contigo al lado de la
calle de la carretera separan y están
cambiando juegas ruedas así que tienes
uno de los mayores campeones del deporte
cambiando una una rueda de ruedas
neumáticos con un amateur que sólo
estaba aquí a mirar el tour llega a otro
inglés que le da que le da a ir una
bomba de aire para ayudarle con este
incidente mecánico en ganarle dice
después mira
sácame el maillot eso es tuyo y así es
que el ciclismo es el deporte en el que
cada uno cada campeón habla con cada fan
pues nos creamos con con esas con este
apunte de anécdotas muchísimas gracias
así un placer compartir con ustedes
también anna y benoit este este tiempo
hablando analizando lo que es el tour de
francia más allá de lo deportivo también
lo social lo económico y al anecdotario
que deja la prueba muchísimas gracias a
los tres ya todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana en primera plana gracias
[Música]